my name is suchitra hari i am the
director of engineering for shared
services at wp engine
shared services is a team that is
focused on our internal stakeholders at
wb engine
a bulk of our focus is on solving for
common problems that happen across
multiple different product lines
and the goal is to solve for problems
holistically instead of one project at a
time the idea is for our developers to
be more in control of when they ship and
what they ship and standardize on common
concerns and hence help our customers
win online
i do want to talk about the team here
you know it sounds as if this is a very
big team it's actually a very small team
we have a product manager an engineering
manager and a solid five member
engineering team and so far our adoption
rates have been
excellent and it's ever growing um every
few weeks we're on boarding a new
engineering team into our platform a new
service or a new application into our
platform
so far uh we've released about 27
applications and services
and as i speak i think that number is
growing growing the improvements to
reliability and our ability to deploy
code with an element of confidence
it just means that this is more time
back
for our application development team
members
to build powerful wordpress products
that's going to help our customers win
online
i'm excited about the possibilities
right i think we could be taking
unleashing the power of full power of
clout to a whole new level at this point
um and that's just going to really help
wp engine customers will online
ultimately it's a huge honor to accept
this award on behalf of wp engine and
our amazing engineers
in the catalyst software delivery
platform team
this recognition comes at a time where
we've just started reaping rewards of
investing in a software delivery
platform built on top of google's
product suite
like i said this is an embodiment our
investment in the sdp is an embodiment
of our core value built for growth being
able to experience lighter operational
burden high availability and ability to
scale rapidly is really important for wp
engines growth at this point
so thank you
like i said i'm super excited about
seeing what unleashing the full power of
cloud is going to bring
in for wp engine in the coming months
and years
so super excited thank you